I used to be a harsh islamophobe at one
time I didn't know a lot about Islam
other than the negative things that I
had heard from other islamophobes like
and a lot of that was due to ignorance
and fear of what I was told you know all
the other career politicians on there
saying Islam hates us they want to kill
us they want to they want to take our
freedoms away and this and that and so
so are you are you ready to actually
take your shahada now I am let's do it
maybe not stick Sammy aside giving a
tour of the D Center what do you think
beautiful beautiful so we transformed
this from people worshiping the creation
to worshiping the Creator Allah bless
your efforts Eddie
how you doing brother
good how you doing man
all right so as you can see we're
getting to work and we need your support
so go ahead and help us to get this
where it's Top Notch inshallah
[Music]
as Eddie was walking me through the
facility he was showing me that he has a
vision of having an Islamic school a
soup kitchen with the neighbors around
here benefit from the generosity of the
Muslims this has the potential to be a
beacon of light for the ummah join us in
this project inshallah so we can
establish the beautiful Dean Center
oh
assalamualaikum greetings of Peace
welcome to the D sharp media host
subscribe hit that notification Bell so
you don't miss exciting episodes like
this one my next guess
went from being a harsh islamophone
listening to Career islamopholes people
who are in the business of lying
spreading misinformation spreading this
manufactured hateness fear capitalizing
on people's ignorance but he said you
know what there's got something
something went off and he said there's
got to be more to the story there's got
to be another side to the story he
looked into Islam and now he's here with
us we're excited to have him on John
Patterson to share with us why he went
from being
islamophobe in the first place a harsh
islamophobe and now he's on the dean
show to take his shahada to accept Islam
we'll be right back with John Patterson
here on the dean show
[Applause]
let me into my face
and his final message
[Music]
the theme show
s
how you doing Dr Bill and our friend
John Patterson is that right I can hear
you John
all right Eddie it's great to meet you
for the first time and um Dr sabil it's
good to meet with you again
uh yes I do have quite the story for you
um so I hope you're ready for it I hope
we have plenty of time to cover all this
I told Dr sabil that I'd like to come up
to
the studio if we don't have enough time
to talk about it all I know Zoom calls
usually only last 45 minutes but uh if
we can cover all of this today
I'm more than happy to do it all right
here and now sounds good where where are
you uh coming in from where are you
located
I live in Ohio around the Dayton area
so tell us uh how we got to where we are
here right now just fill us in with that
how did you get to actually calling did
you call the number did you have you
been watching some of the shows and then
what led you to actually calling up and
now we're here talking
fill us in well
um
I used to be a harsh islamophobe at one
time
um I didn't know a lot about Islam other
than the negative things that I had
heard from other islamophobes like the
Sam shimons of the world the Christian
princes of the world and the David Woods
of the world and what have you
and that had formed a very negative
image of Islam within me and a lot of
that was due to ignorance and fear of
what I was told not what is what is
actually in the Quran how Muslims
actually live how they treat other
people
and so
I guess I should go back to where
it all started around 9 11. before then
I didn't know anything about Islam like
most Americans
don't uh if you look at where we're
geographically located I think the
closest Muslim majority nation is in
Morocco which is like 6 000 miles away
and across two separate oceans
but after 9 11 happened
that's when it started to get my
attention about Islam along with so many
other people's attention about Islam in
a negative way
and that was in part because you had
politicians like George W bush and Dick
Cheney and you know all the other career
politicians on there saying Islam hates
us they want to kill us they want to
they want to take our freedoms away and
this and that and so
I think that's when
when you see islamophobia today
and how bad it is that is when it really
started it was around 9 11 and then of
course
uh after the U.S invasion of Iraq and
Afghanistan
after we had pulled out of Iraq and then
you had the power vacuum which led to
the formation of Isis
uh and you and these all the Terrible
Things That Isis was doing uh to Muslims
and to Christians and to to anyone else
that threw gasoline on the fire with
islamophobia and that's when you saw
just in my opinion when you saw
These Guys these islamophobic guys uh
come up on the internet and gained
popularity and all of that
they did so at a time when Isis was
really really active I mean you had the
terrible incidents like
uh the beheading of certain
reporters and uh I mean just I don't
want to go into all the graphic things
that Isis did I'm sure that you
gentlemen know uh what they all did
but that that is when the career
islamophobes really started to gain
popularity and then you know of course
you had 911 before that but before these
two those two things happened
you didn't really
I mean islamophobia I mean it was it was
a little active but it wasn't as much as
as it is today
and and so because of my fear of Islam
and things that had been taught to me
about Islam but not what I actually knew
about Islam
when you have somebody who doesn't know
any better and they hear these things
constantly by politicians and other
islamophobic actors it creates a
negative image of Islam based on fear in
ignorance
and so I used to say a lot of uh
terrible things about Islam about the
prophet of Islam about uh
about Muslims when I didn't really know
who you were I had an image of you that
was taught to me by other people I I
didn't know about the prophet of Islam
and the
and for example I didn't know that
for the first 13 years
after he became a prophet he suffered
some of the most brutal persecution at
the hands of the quraish
uh before God finally gave him
permission to defend himself
I mean him and his companions had had
suffered physical beatings I mean they
were driven out of places that they had
lived and it wasn't until finally after
13 years did God give him permission to
defend himself and fight back see I
didn't know that
um
basically what I was taught about the
prophet was he was just this guy who who
got on his camel and picked up his
swords with all of his companions and
they went around the desert just killing
Christians and Jews and this and that
and so that is what formed the the
negative image of Islam Within Me
but
I remember when I was
when I was active against Islam one of
the things I used to
have in the back of my mind is you know
maybe there's more to the story maybe
there's
maybe what I'm being taught isn't
entirely accurate maybe I'm being unjust
and
and so
finally a few years back I just decided
to
um
just to take a break from politics and
religion in general
and I decided to you know just uh
uh concentrate on my relationship with
God
and
and so I decided to leave that path
and not be active on social media
anymore in regards to this stuff now
as far as me being involved in that
movement
nobody ever heard of me but then again I
wasn't really active on YouTube it was
mostly on my Facebook account with a few
you know friends of mine here and there
I mean I'm not excusing the the attitude
that I had I I just uh
I wasn't really interested in making a
business out of it that some of these
other people that are
uh in the islamophobia business are and
to be clear
islamophobia is a business
you these people that are involved on
these sites that are going after Islam
they're doing it for patreon donations
for views they they want Muslims to be
angry they want Muslims to be divided
they want acts of terrorism so that they
can then turn around and take verses
from the Quran the Sunnah and the Hadith
and then shotgunning on the internet to
people who just don't know any better
that's that's the entire goal
I have a quick question to ask you right
at you know where you stopped here
um
you know there are so many other faiths
out there there are so many religions
out there what made you to consider
Islam I know that uh you woke up to
Islam at 9-1-1 I guess right just like
many other Americans
so why consider Islam you know you could
have just thought okay fine Islam is one
more faith but why look into it and now
today trying to commit to it
that's a good question
um
I think the first uh thing that comes to
mind is
when you look at the Old Testament of
the Bible and the attributes
and and dictates of God in the Old
Testament
with how he governed a society with the
guidance he gave to the prophets with
the consistent message of worshiping one
God not two not three not
not many gods
and then when when I did get curious and
read the Quran I saw
huge similarities between the god of the
Quran and the god of the Old Testament
of the Bible
and and so that got me even more Curious
you see
what a lot of the islamophobes don't
realize is the more you go after Islam
it's going to get people curious about
it as it did with me and so
so I started looking at the Old
Testament I started looking at you know
the Quran to see the similarities
then I took into account that
there's so many different versions of
Christianity
that to try to pick the right one is
like playing the lottery I mean with my
respect to
other Christians out there I mean I mean
so and Jesus himself said in the New
Testament of the Bible that he would
have one flock in one Shepherd so he
made clear he was opposed to the idea of
many different sects of Christianity and
schools of thought about Christianity
and and denominations of Christianity
Jesus himself made that clear he said
one flock and one Shepherd
then I also looked at um
how
Jesus said in the New Testament
he limited himself to that of a human
like he
when he would say he of he himself he
can do nothing without God's approval
so
how can Jesus be God if he's saying he
needs the approval of God to do
something
other times when Jesus said
um when he told one of and I forget the
verse you know you know excuse me for
that but he told one of his people that
was asking a question
um why do you call me good you know no
one is good but God Alone
and so
and so that really uh made me start to
question
the things that I was taught about you
know Christianity and who Jesus was then
I also looked at the Council of nicaea
which most Christians don't even know
about the Council of nicaea they have no
idea how there was a lot of books that
were compiled to be put in the Bible
that were rejected
and as far as I know we don't know what
was in those books we don't know what
was said
there could have been conflicting
reports about Jesus and his message that
were rejected at the Council of nicaea
for whatever the reason
and so my question is why why were these
books rejected why were only Matt Mark
Luke and John
included in the New Testament of the
Bible and then of course you had the
Epistles from Paul and then you had
uh of course you know Peter and and the
book of Acts and all of that and that's
fine but why were these other books
rejected right so John in the Council of
nicaea you know books could have been a
matter of discussion but mostly what
happened in there it was monotheism was
diluted
they equated uh Jesus along with God
so now they have a binity then in the
year 381 or so that's when they included
the holy ghost or the Holy Spirit and
that's how the Trinity was formulated
right so Council of Nigeria was dilution
of monotheism
and that's not the first time I've heard
that
and so so basically that's three almost
400 years after the death of Jesus
was the trinity
was the Trinity actually formed yeah and
and so
and so again that that when when you
looked at the similarities of the Old
Testament new and and the Quran with
God's attributes and the similarities
there
and I want to take a minute to get back
to the messenger Muhammad peace be upon
him yes and I
when I found out that he he was not
involved in an act of violence until
after 13 years of brutal persecution
that really wanted me to
look more into his life and to see
exactly who this man actually was
and I remember thinking that
assuming this man was just this awful
person that that so many Islam folks say
that why would over a billion people
follow him I mean are they all insane
are they all crazy uh
and so that didn't make sense to me how
if this man was just a terrible person
how could all these people follow him
and so I got on YouTube one day
and I wanted to to actually see what the
Muslims have to say about Muhammad peace
be upon him and so there's a YouTube
video entitled the life of Muhammad by
Yusuf Islam it's about
it's only about an hour long but it
talks about how when he was born
um he was born in very harsh conditions
obviously from being in the desert he
was an orphan
he lost both of his parents
uh how he was called the most
trustworthy person
by the people who knew him
and how
it was at the age of 40. so he had lived
you know half of his life by the time he
was given his first revelation
um
and so
and even after he was given the first
revelation he
you know he was afraid he didn't know if
if he should continue going forth on
this path so
what I'm getting at is he didn't wake up
just one day and decide to throw off his
life the life that he had been living
and then take on this life of brutal
persecution and to try to
continue to spread the message of one
God and I mean it's a beautiful uh
presentation of his life
and then it talks about how
uh he was driven out of Mecca and how he
how he had sought Refuge first in a
Christian town I forget the name I think
it's modern day Ethiopia today
and all the times that he tried to make
peace
all the times that he had tried to
uh
just preach his religion peacefully was
met with hostility and violence
and so
when I look at all of that
along with the doubts that I had had
about Christianity
I think that's what finally uh
wanted me to accept Islam and to embrace
Islam was
was uh and then I look at how charitable
Muslims are today
you're the most charitable people on the
face of the Earth
uh not even any other religion comes
close when I look at your sense of
community that you all have
um that's when I decided I wanted to uh
to become a Muslim and to embrace the
faith of Islam when I found out who
Muhammad really was the person that he
really was not what was told to me by
other people who
you know for whatever the reason just
want to make a profit on the internet
um and and when I was involved in that
negative stuff I didn't care about money
I was genuinely afraid
you know I didn't I didn't care about
making a profit and or any of that so
and so that's when I put aside all my
biases
about Islam and I decided to contact Dr
sabil
and uh I wish I would have originally
taken my shahada around two years ago Dr
Seville when I originally
uh had contacted you
at the time my see with my wife
when she found out I wanted to embrace
Islam after being a harsh islamophobe
for
uh for so long it was quite a shock to
her and so it took me a while to
actually show her the teachings of what
Muhammad actually taught and what he
stood for
so it took me a while to to win her over
and while I wish I still would have
taken my shahada then
um now I feel I'm finally ready and so
now I tried to compact a lot
a lot of that
into this presentation today because I
didn't know how much time you guys had
and and
you know there's so much more I wanted
to address I've been talking with
brother sabile I've been texting him
about
different uh
thoughts and ideas I've had to expand
the tawa
uh Brothers to Bill I saw your your your
video where you had said
25 000 people in America embrace the
faith of Islam
every year and then you don't really
hear from him that much after that and I
think I under
if I may I think I have an idea on how
we can
on how we can stop that you see
most churches in America today
once somebody becomes a part of their
faith
their happy for them and all of that but
after they accept the faith they're not
really involved in
their lives anymore I mean they don't
call them they don't check up on them
they don't invite them to go do things
together and
so I see an opportunity for the dawa
here in America today
when somebody Embraces the faith of
Islam
we need to bring them in as a part of
the family we need to look after them we
need to check up on them and so
you're as Muslims let me say something
your greatest strength that you have and
never forget this is your sense of
community
America right now is a very
country politically
uh
there's really no sense of community
left in America anymore
and so while I don't wish Misfortune
upon anyone in my country today it
there's an opportunity now for Islam to
to offer Islam and to say that hey
whatever you may be lacking in the
community today
we can fill that void and just just
bring up what Islam has to offer
you know any good salesman will tell you
that
that the facts are always secondary to
the feelings and I'm not saying to
dilute the facts or anything what I'm
saying is there's an opportunity now for
the doubt one to present that Community
to Market that community and to say you
know hey you know if you become a Muslim
you'll have brothers and sisters for
Life we'll look after you
and you'll always have a family that'll
always be there yes brother John that's
a good observation and uh you know with
Allah's help and you getting involved
right I wish for you we wish for you
that you become uh is father of Islam a
speaker of Islam a sharer of Islam and
an ambassador of Islam all right so
that's my prayer that's our Dua
supplication for you that we need good
people we need good humans Allah has
honored you Allah has guided you so all
of us together inshallah we can show the
realities of Islam that what Islam is
not but what Islam is
so when I heard your story I have uh you
know feelings of Joy then have feelings
of sadness
the sadness is because you know there
could be millions of people just like
yourself who have not waken up to the
positive aspect of Islam to what Islam
really is you only know Islam what the
media is saying so that's the sad part
but I'm joyous for you and many other
Americans who actually woke up to Islam
and now they have investigated Islam
from a you know unbiased point of view
watching the videos converting with
people asking questions
seeking Allah's help
so that's where we want many of the
people all of the people to me and all
of us together inshallah with Allah's
guidance we can do that
so inshallah right so without delay
brother Eddie
whether John mashallah is ready for
shahada today is a really blessed day
auspicious day the day of Friday I mean
any day is good for shahada Brother John
but today is a very special day Friday
right Friday
so before we recite the shahada what we
usually do is for those who may be
listening who may not know what shahada
is before a person Embraces Islam uh
they need to recite the testimony of
faith in English so they can understand
and for the sake of formality also in
Arabic
but before they do that it's important
for a person to also know the
fundamentals of Islam even though you
may have been doing research for two
years three years or maybe 23 years
since 9-1-1 it's important for you to
know brother John just a six billion
than the Five Pillars at least
right so at least you would know that
what you're coming into
and then you would be saying the shahada
with full Consciousness in the context
of those beliefs and those pillars
so you may already be aware of the six
beliefs the very first one is to believe
in the absolute Oneness of God that God
is only one he's not one in three he's
not a human he's not an idol he's not a
creation he's the creator of the whole
creation
the second important belief is to
believe in the angels that God has
created
the third one is to believe in all the
messengers and Prophets that God has
appointed to guide Humanity see to guide
Humanity God himself does not come down
and becomes human
but he he picks any honors from the
humans Messengers and Prophets and then
he sends Revelation to them and they in
turn they say they share the Revelation
with their people
so who do you think brother John is a
very first prophet and the last prophet
according to Islam
I would say from what the
little research I've done the first
prophet would be Adam
and the last prophet would be Muhammad
peace be upon him
very good peace be upon all the prophets
and Messengers and we take Jesus to be
only as a prophet not as God not Son of
God but one of the prophets in the chain
in the chain of prophethood
okay that's very good and number fourth
believe is to believe in all the books
that God has revealed as a guidance to
humanity so the previous books uh given
to Moses and Abraham and David and Jesus
peace be upon them
they were not preserved people change
them we don't have them in the pure form
so God sent the final book the Quran as
a guidance for Humanity and the Quran is
the one God has made the commitment to
protect it
so I was saying that we believe in the
Divine Revelations that came before the
Quran we believe in them in the original
form but not in the current uh altered
form that they have so Quran is the last
revelation God has sent for all of
Humanity's guidance through prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him
all right so the Quran and the prophetic
example they form the basic teachings of
Islam the basic guidance
the fifth believe brother John is to
believe in the day of Resurrection in
the day of judgment you know just like
at the end of a semester when we went to
school there is evaluation
at the end of our life and God will
bring us back to life would be our grand
evaluation of how we live this life
so on that day a person goes to Paradise
by Allah's Mercy if he or she had the
right belief worshiping and submitting
on to only one God and then doing the
good deeds to the best of their ability
if they fall short they directly pray to
God nobody dies for us there is no
mediator between us and the Creator
and the last important belief is to
believe in the Divine decree that means
anything good or bad is coming from God
Allah we have to be content with what
Allah has given to us
so those are the six important beliefs
brother John do you do you understand
them and do you do you accept them
yeah and he he talked about the
listening and being influenced by the
career islamophobes the people who make
a living
so they're setting up the most obstacles
spreading the most misinformation these
careers he called them islamophobes and
he was a fan of theirs he was following
their content he was probably
regurgitating much of the same nonsense
much of the false information but
alhamdulillah then he as he said he
wanted to know if he was actually it was
another side to the story so he wanted
to know if there was another side of the
story which there was he got informed
properly and he's here with us
alhamdulillah
you know many times alhamdulillah right
it has a positive effect
when people are saying something wrong
about Islam more people get curious
about Islam even with the Quran burning
that happened in Norway in the
Scandinavian countries what the French
president was saying about the hijab ban
what people are saying and doing on the
internet it just makes a person curious
you know people are intelligent humans
so people become curious why would two
billion people would be following uh
Islam and Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him and the Quran so we as Muslims we
keep on doing what is right what is true
without any distraction no matter what
they say what they do islamophobes we
keep on adhering and with focus and you
know razor sharp uh Focus as we say
on sharing the faith Allah guides from
he Wills our job is just to make sure
that we keep on conveying the message
with the right methodology and mashallah
brother John is one of those individuals
despite all the negative islamophobia in
this country around the world mashallah
inshallah he gets back with us he's
having some technical difficulties John
all right guys I'm back
were I could hear everything you were
saying but my my internet was cutting
out and
it it ended up kicking me right out of
the stream and I was trying to get your
attention but it just but it no worries
no worries Dr sapil went over the six
articles of Faith were you able to catch
that were you able to hear it did you
were you able to understand it yep yes I
I did hear all of them
um I could tell that it was cutting out
but I did catch all of them yes okay Dr
Bill go ahead and continue from there
yeah so really important now the five
important pillars the very first one is
to recite the testimony of faith that
there is no other God besides one God
Allah and Muhammad peace be upon Him of
Allah so Muslims replied it many times
and that was the main article the main
pillar of faith which in color very soon
you are going to do it today the second
one is to pray five times a day
and inshallah God willing we can send
you some literature we can include you
into the classes that also show you how
to pray the five daily prayers
the third one is to give obligatory
charity uh 2.5 percent of our safe
assets at least once a year for the poor
the needy and the people who are less
fortunate and beyond that you can give
any amount as we want and you said you
know Muslims are the most charitable
actually according to the survey in the
U.S in the UK in which Europe Muslims
are the most charitable people in the
world
the third pillar is to fast in the
fasting which is coming up next week
brother John around 22nd of March
have you ever fasted before
not really I mean
uh
um and I was going to say I still have a
lot to learn
um about Islam about the culture
um and so I look forward to doing all of
that I mean I've fasted here and there
when
uh when I still consider myself a
Christian and there's so much more that
I that I want to speak with you guys
about Eddie I hope that you will
give me the opportunity to come to the
dean show in Chicago where we can
actually sit down and maybe take an hour
to to talk about
um various ways to expand the dawa and I
could share with you my ideas I've been
sharing a lot of them with Brothers
sabiel and um
also
um
about uh
where the country is at and how it
presents a huge opportunity for Islam
and so I hope I can get that opportunity
with you one day we could do it proper
in person yeah
there's a lot more I wanted to talk
about but we're trying to condense all
this in a you know in a short video so I
just it's it's not the same as really
being able to take my time and speak
like I would yes
and I have a gift for both of you see
I've got my shahada ring right here
I got a couple of them on Amazon and you
know I can't believe how beautifully
they came out for you know I think I got
this from shahada ring huh
I was surprised my brother John said
that yesterday that there is a shahada
ring nowadays tonight
so it okay well it's just it has it in
Arabic on one side and then when you
turn it over it has it in English and
you know I've just been wearing it the
past few days and I got one for you and
one for Eddie so I look forward to uh
thank you so are you are you ready to
actually take your shahada now
I am let's do it alhamdulillah let me
just complete this so the fourth pillar
is uh fast in the month of fasting
Ramadan and the last pillar is to go
once in a lifetime at least for
pilgrimage if the means allows it
besides the Five Pillars brother John a
person a Muslim always have to Aspire to
gain knowledge knowledge is obligatory
in Islam good knowledge beneficial
knowledge
I hear you can you hear me
okay I turned the camera off so I
noticed it was starting to come back
again or they're starting to cut out
again I so I just I turned the camera
off just so you guys could hear me but
everybody knows what I look like so okay
let's do it brother I'm ready
[Music]
go ahead
so please repeat after me brother John I
bear Witness
I bear Witness
there is no other God there is no other
God
besides Allah besides Allah
and I bear with me and I bear Witness
upon him
that Muhammad peace be upon him is the
messenger of Allah is the messenger of
Allah
for the sake of formality so please
repeat after me
Allah
congratulations
I never thought this day would come I
never thought I'd be sitting here today
converting to Islam after my
uh after all the history that uh that is
involved in my life
there's hope for others who are
following that same way of being harsh
islamophobes listening to Career
islamophobes that they wanted to know
the other side of the story like you did
you got educated properly you're seeking
the guidance from the Creator and here
we are alhamdulillah
and and once again guys I apologize for
my phone cutting out I've how
embarrassing I I apologize for that
he'll do it proper no worries yeah and
uh but brother Eddie there's so much
more in brother Seville there's so much
more I wanted to say
islamophobia is a business and
if they don't have patreon donations if
they if people are not watching
then then they're gonna go away but but
more importantly here's what I would say
to my brothers and sisters in Islam
don't worry about them
and all they can do is make YouTube
videos they can go after Islam and
attack Islam they can say whatever they
want
but once people start seeing the good
nature of Muslims in Islam once they
start feeling that sense of community
once they see your good nature your
charity eventually
the islamophobes can scream as loud as
they want they can do whatever they want
but it's in the end it's not going to
admit it's not going to matter
and last thing I would I want to say is
that um
the messenger made clear that Islam
would enter every house
and before the day of judgment that it
would be the world's predominant faith
and it's happening so
they can say what they want they can do
what they want but don't worry about
them
just concentrate on your dawa
concentrate on your good deeds and in
the end uh a law is going to Prevail
what one last thing before we conclude
we got one minute left for the people
out there who are listening
similar situation they've been listening
to do the career islamophobes now
they're listening to you what advice
would you have for them to break through
some of this fear and this ignorance
I would say talk go go talk to some
Muslims and see what they have to say
get a copy of the Quran and actually
read it put aside all your biases
and
and you know they're friendly they'll be
happy to have you and uh you know once
you do you'll be glad you did you know
don't you know don't let that fear and
ignorance take over don't let it drive
your your thought process go and speak
to people like brothers Seville and
brother Eddie they'd be they'd be happy
to have you absolutely
thank you very much congratulations
again brother
welcome to Islam now you should share
the message with people around you
starting with your family neighbors and
all of you manage I look forward to that
and learning how learning how to pray
and yes you know there's so much I have
to learn now
and that will get you started we can
appoint a mentor from you last is for
you right this is the services from the
Muslim Community mashallah and gain
peace and being sure to you so happy for
you may Allah make you strong in faith
may Allah help you to read more and to
practice more and share this wonderful
Faith starting with your family and the
rest of humanity congratulations
congratulations brother
thank you
all right thank you guys
having this opportunity both of us to uh
share in this wonderful day jamad day
and also this brother Abdullah accepted
Islam from a harsh islamophobe to
someone who has submitted his will to
the creator of heavens and the earth a
Muslim alhamdulillah
this Amana of the people very seriously
he was just sharing a story with me that
they had some benches inside that needed
to be moved and Eddie together Father
and Son were lifting these benches join
us in this project inshallah so we can
establish beautiful